naja was geht und herzlich willkommen
zum heutigen video ich dachte mir heute
lasse ich mich mal schminken also das
ist irgendwie so ein trend auf youtube
dass man sich von seiner freundin
schwingendes und was machst du schon
wieder habe ich dir nicht gesagt dass
sie nicht verblödet hat sie läuft wieder
okay was mal auf du hast dich bereit
erklärt nicht zu schmecken stellt das
kannst du dich gut schwingen
ich habe mich für dich selbst oft ja was
ist jetzt gerade zurzeit so rauch meine
leute sind übrigens immer noch damit
beschäftigt also ich bin immer noch
beschäftigt luca was wir freunde aber
hat auch mal mit von dem riesen sneakers
die reste termine das video sehen wollt
bürgerbefragung
jetzt ist man nicht so viel also womit
fängt mal an ok das hab ich mir gedacht
in dem das hat manches extra für dich
würde ich immer ob man dreht es auch
dann bringt es nicht auf das hast du ich
hab halt hochwertigere produkte das
auftreten man hat nur den deckel ab und
dann spricht man zwar sie oft auf dem
youtube länder sind jetzt richtig
das passiert mir noch mal was macht es
damit verschieben das ist gespannt nicht
in meiner ausbildung also es ist ja ist
ja mehr oder weniger würde mir mehr
üblich dass auch männer sich mit
schminke aus leben und du machst mir
erstmal erst mal so einen richtigen look
bei mir
neben noch ein bisschen ich mache jetzt
hier um einen punkt das machen schminkt
dann brauchst du auf die nase und unten
so redest du von baby
wir nehmen hier noch ein bisschen
als nächstes haben wir mithelfen
webkonzern komplett ganze was man wählt
das drehen wir jetzt auch auf die muss
man lerne deine haare zu bändigen man
halt mal das heißt es immer
das ist jetzt ein
361 jetzt weiß ich jetzt sehen wir den
pinsel freundin 38,00 sind egal heute
darf ich auch wünsche äußern ein team
geworden
ich habe angst meine augen zu öffnen
das ist so ungesund
das ganze ist es nirgends spiegel wo ich
mich darin sehen könnte als nächstes
haben wir leute habe ich das gefühl dass
nicht gut wird ja ist das teil des make
ups aus meinem mund mein ganzes leben
sind dreckig mal abstimmen auf die
kammer und der film im boxkeller hin
das habe ich habe gedacht wenn dann dann
drei vielleicht mitmachen
damit kann das zähneputzen ist das
sicher nicht die augen worden oder so zu
bürsten
broken franken ich bin überall verfolgt
mit diesem zweig was ist gut was machen
wir als nächstes luzie es nachrichtlich
schaffen ich mache ein bisschen heute so
ein bisschen verspielten look würde ich
mal sagen
daher nehmen dafür ja ein bisschen was
von dem pinken auf dem pinsel dafür auch
nicht so genau jetzt ist das nach der
lidschatten warum seine nase blau was
hast du damit gemacht was genau steckt
aber du machst das team eine tochter
hier unsere tochter
mal sehen wie lange ich das mal mit dir
aushalten
das machen wir den lippen
dann fahren wir hier einen hendrix
das als meine damit herrn der software
bequem kann ich nur empfehlen das
glänzend vorbereitet habe ist operieren
es ist ein bis zwei herz lacht nach
einer kamera das ist ein guter freund
des gestorbenen zeigt weltkrieg
geschmeckt der hund rannte man kann aber
auch mit dem regieren wo gott nein da
ist ein bisschen metallteile und ich
sehe gerade so miniatur bild von mir in
der reflexion sie einfach scheiße geil
aus
so starb in ein loch und jetzt tue ich
jetzt unter der marke jetzt die obama
transformation
die leute sollen jetzt auch mal ein
leitfaden für alle aktien oder also wenn
ihr objektivieren nicht kennt und aber
mir weil hier gibt es öfters video über
allergien und als nächstes haben wir
viel die einzelnen produkten ziemlich
gut kann es
also ich würde sagen ich muss das noch
erklärt für die leute ganz kurz bevor du
dich selber sehen erklärt warum sowas
gemacht hast du hast hier nach dem dank
wird auf jeden fall dass des jahres
erklären wir dennoch ist es ein
natürlicher look oder ist doch sowas
gewagtes zu dem haus gefahren
es ist als gewagtes zum ausgehen oder so
der look ist perfekt und scheinheilig
man fällt nicht direkt auf trotzdem
natürliche schönheit natürlich vertreten
in den augen unter den roten auch über
einen da ist doch genommen aber ich hab'
ich bin alex olivia so ein bisschen
unter den augen vertreten habe darauf
geachtet dass der lippenstift wirklich
konstant nur auf den lippen wirklich
vertreten ist immer nur auf den lippen
okay ich würde ich will jetzt nicht zu
nahe treten also aber ich sehe aus wie
so ein keine ahnung wieso ein
stammesoberhaupt in irgendeinem
afrikanischen ureinwohner stammen oder
so ich versuche mich erst mal wieder mit
luzifer ich meine dieses jahres hin und
schminke
ich hab jetzt nochmal genauer
hingeschaut und ich finde sie echt schön
aus